[Music]
hey everyone I'm ash Crossan and here to
talk about his new movie 211 is cory
hardrict hi hey doing I'm great thank
you for having me looking dapper oh yeah
before I love the shirt matches the logo
right I'm here well you've got an
exciting new movie with an exciting cast
the premise is a bank robbery heist
it's based on off of the 1997 it was a
true bank robbery that happened in North
Hollywood here and that's where they got
the code 211 it's like police code for
bank robbery okay and yeah it was it was
chaotic it was everything all bad so we
the movies based off that actual the
true events and we shot it and the cage
is my partner he's like the leader and
we go in just a normal day on duty and
the next thing you know we get this car
to go to the scene and then mayhem
ensues for for hours and hours and
that's what the film was about oh yeah
yeah do you play a real person or is it
just based on the true events and you're
a fictional yeah he was a real person
but they actually changed you know his
ethnic background so african-american
and the role was colorless and I was
like cool that's that's even better for
me yeah and yeah so it was it was cool
it was great experience I think everyone
on earth wants to know everything about
working with Nicholas Cage yeah oh man
he's crazy man in a good way he has so
much energy and he's like I said he's
he's one of the greatest guys like
professionals I've ever worked with and
he's so calm and cool and laid back and
relaxed but when it's time to go he's
just like boom he's like right there so
I was like one big tennis match throwing
scenes back and forth to each other
throughout the film so I learned a lot
from him what surprised you most about
working with him how laid-back he is he
doesn't let nothing rattle him you know
it can be explosive so it's nothing you
know I just you know there's nothing you
know it's like he's not worried and it's
just kind of like he's been doing this a
while Wow you know yeah that's cool
there's anyone to do like a chaotic
movie with yeah
there were a few times when he was like
got vintage Nicky Kay's like oh you know
dot diving all over the plays and
screaming so that was kind of cool like
we're playing a drinking game to Nick
Cage yeah you learned a lot from him is
there like a certain piece of advice
that kind of stuck with you well he just
said have fun you know just have fun as
long as you having fun you're doing the
right thing and that's what he told me
he kept it real simple as long as you're
having fun I never work a day in your
life never work a day in your life right
I don't know if it's true I read he
broke his ankle and said oh wow I didn't
know we were allowed to talk about that
but yeah he um you know so engulfed in
the character broke his ankle really I'm
not in trouble get in trouble by saying
no I didn't ever would do that but yeah
he uh he healed up pretty good came we
came back we had a little downtime and
we finished a project you know they put
his stunt double in for some stuff that
he couldn't do of course he couldn't
like run full-speed no more but uh you
know put his guy in there and from the
back he's running and you couldn't tell
he looked just like him
Wow so did that was they must be you
know must have been pretty intense
filming then like did you know man she
get roughed up at all well I got roughed
up a lot like like my knees and elbows
and stuff like that and a lot of the
bullet fragments were like pop like down
my my vest and go in hit my skin and
it's Barney yeah and I'm trying to shoot
well like I'm like oh my god and it's
going down the hole light from the shirt
to the leg it's like hot it's hard
because it's you know they're still
blank there's still like bullets but
they're just blanks but I'm sure you
feel the same impact that's a lot of
times you know these props on set people
are like oh like it's just fake stuff
and you're like yeah it doesn't mean it
doesn't hurt yeah they're real guns is
just blanks so it's like if you put your
hand you can like shoot a hole in your
hand or something or can or just blow it
blow it to pieces yeah jeez did you do
like any kind of boot camp yeah we hit a
boot camp for like a week when we got
there and then we went to the gun range
and did that for like a couple days but
I had a lot of experience from prior
films so I just brought that into what I
what I learned here yeah I just took it
to the to the character what else do you
have coming up cuz you've got a lot
going on in your life wow I have a lot
why I go back to season
two of the oath it's on crackle Sony is
uh like their biggest show and we go
back in Puerto Rico shooting a couple
weeks ryan Kwanten plays my older
brother some some great cast executive
brews by 50 cent and created by joe - it
was a real police officer so I can't
wait to do that and then I have city of
Lies coming out September 7 with Johnny
Depp and Forest Whitaker and then after
that I go to Bulgaria Morocco to shoot
the outpost with Earl and Oh bloom it's
got Eastwood Wow yeah you have a newborn
I have a newborn my beautiful daughter
yes she's a month old
what's it been like having it it's your
first daughter right you have a sign
I'll be seven a couple weeks how was he
doing as an older brother so far he's
doing great he's going to get bottles
he's helping get the Pampers I mean he
doesn't like to get the pamper and throw
it in the waste you know he's just like
I don't want that but I would get a
cleaner yeah
but he's uh he's looking forward to like
going on vacation with her we're going
Hawaii like he's he's really being a big
brother now he's maturing a lot I love
that yeah what excites you the most
about having a daughter just how
delicate and precious she is you know
she looks like a little angel she looks
like a doll when I show her pictures
I'll show you like a photo before we go
but she looks like a little doll and she
stares in my eyes and it's just like she
just sucked me into her soul you know
and it's just like I'm like oh my gosh
man you know I'll do anything for that
for that little ones
yeah it's it's a precious moment
precious time in my life right now
we are very very obsessed with with your
relationship you and tea are just like
so in love yes that's that's my baby I
love it yeah how do you guys balance cuz
I think I think it's tough to date
someone in the same industry as you or
in the same flight that's the same job
as you right right so how do you guys
balance you know when you're both
getting projects coming your way how do
you guys kind of balance like hey you're
gonna take this I'm gonna take this down
the road kind of stuff
no I mean we make it work I mean she
tries to get they she actually we make
it work far as we try not to go two or
three weeks without seeing each other
you know like chewy to come to where I'm
at or I'll come back home that's kind of
the agreement we have to keep the family
tight and strong and keep the relates
ship everything good so so this year
they're not gonna be able to come to
Puerto Rico but they're gonna come to
Europe when I film the outposts and I'm
gonna come home as much as I can
yeah you know we make it work we make it
work you guys did what your 10 year
anniversary
10th anniversary April 20th and we've
been together for 18 years there since
I've been here in California that's so
beautiful
yeah that's great no I was like what do
you know whenever I'm about to interview
somebody I kind of go down through their
credits and I I noticed that your very
first credit ever was an episode of
smart guy Wow yes it was it was oh that
was ages ago
yes like 97 it was a long time ago and I
remember I just crashed that audition I
was ass out here visiting for a little
bit and I crashed the audition and I got
like a co-starter part and her brother
Todd she's my brother he's great he
jumped on my back and I was gonna fight
him he was like this tall then you know
and we squared up in the hallway and
that was all I had that's so funny
though what are the chances he's like
he's my brother you know so it's you
know it's crazy this is crazy right this
is a crazy thing yeah yeah to 11 where
when can we see it you can watch it
today in selected theaters and on VOD in
digital HD you don't want to miss it
this great movie
[Music]